oh sure you mentioned Ed Burns you know
we know you had a chance to sit down
with that burns at this past year's
Sundance what is he doing that you love
to see more independent filmmakers doing
that he really does think about the
audience that he has I mean he's lucky
and that he isn't starting from zero
he's been an independent filmmakers
since the night early 90s you know so
he's and he got picked up in the
traditional system and he's been able to
benefit both by be an actor and also
being a writer director so he can't
totally be matched you know by the
average indeed person who's just
starting out but what I like about him
as far as being sort of a celebrity name
of doing it is that he does really
devote himself to thinking about okay
who are my most engaged people and how
can i distribute my work specifically to
them and I think as you saw in the piece
that he realized in the mid-2000s that a
lot of his audience was telling him that
you know we like we'd love to see your
films but they never come to the theater
near us they always have such a limited
release and it's somewhere down in the
big city and we don't go down there very
often so we have to wait and sometimes
we would have to wait nine months to a
year and p.m. we forgot about them you
know we didn't know where they would be
so now he really pushes for online
release where everybody has access to
them and he's fine with it like he's
adapted his thinking as a filmmaker from
it has to be in a theater too I just
want people to see my work and it
doesn't matter to me where they see it
that's incredible healthy you know
attitude to have and it's much more
profitable you know then pushing
yourself through that old traditional
mindset of it has to be on a big screen
and it has to go to DVD next and then it
goes to digital after that and then it
goes to Netflix or television or
wherever that that thinking more with
your audience in mind and that's going
back to you who's your audience not just
identifying who they are but how do they
consume media and how will i distribute
it based on how they consume media not
based on how the industry tells me I
should release it
and how I personally feel like I should
release it because of this industry
pressure now it doesn't mean that you
can't be aware of Windows that if you
really do have broadcast potential for
your film you're not going to want to
release it on netflix first because that
negates having that and it's very tricky
to tell people yeah this film doesn't
have any broadcast potential because
there's inevitably somebody who comes
along and goes I got a broadcast daily
and so it's hard it is hard to determine
early on you know okay we're not even
going to go for cable VOD because if we
don't have a significant theatrical it's
not likely to get cable VOD so we'll
just go straight to iTunes and Netflix
um you know I don't know any filmmakers
now who don't want to see their film on
a screen in some way it doesn't have to
necessarily be a traditional cinema it
could be in you know conference rooms it
could be in the community centers it
could be in churches you know those are
still public gatherings where live
people sit together in a communal
atmosphere to watch a movie and those
are still legitimate you know
experiences that people are getting just
as if they went down to the Metroplex
and sat in the theater seats you know I
also like the aspect of of coming to the
qas and having your screenings be
special events a reason give people a
reason why they don't want to wait for
it to come to iTunes or wait for it to
go to Netflix or just stay home and
watch it if you have some kind of life
experience component to your screenings
that they could never replicate at home
that experience they will come you know
that this is something special something
worth leaving my house for but the good
thing you know about Edward is that he
really does care about who's watching
and he's taken that into consideration
and he talks to people you know he said
that I love Twitter I love talking with
people on Twitter and he's really open
to that he doesn't see himself as on an
unattainable celebrity and who are you
people i don't have time for you he
makes time he understands this is a
value not just not just from a marketing
i don't think the
does it totally with them that predatory
I cuz I'm going to need to use these
people so I'm going to do this a little
bit now because I'll need their help and
and I'm going to use them later he does
it in such a way that they say how can
we help you that's what you want you
want people to be it you know how think
it's a privilege to help you not feel
put upon that they're coerced into doing
this because you've deigned to speak to
them you know a little bit so to sort of
changing that mindset of being more open
to talking to people on a human level
even if it's using a tool that's not
face-to-face it's still human
communication you still are human and
they are and treat them with the respect
you would treat somebody who was
standing live in front of you
you